we have some exciting news to announce
here at CBS this morning Diana Miller
has been named the new executive
producer of our show diana is an Emmy
Peabody and Duke DuPont award-winning
producer
she's a proven leader in our newsroom
helping guide this shows coverage since
joining the team in 2014 that she has
diana has overseen numerous exclusive
interviews including sit-down with
Virginia Governor Ralph Northam and that
interview with our Kelly is live in
girlfriends and the interviews with his
accusers now this is also a very cool
thing audience people all three morning
network news shows
listen to this are led by women Wow I
know I saw that this morning I thought
well - we're excited about the future
for us here at CBS this morning with
Diane at the helm and it's big ol shout
out - yeah and we should mention even
Nordstrom has led our control room for
the past you know several several months
the entire team we don't ever skip a
beat here on CBS this morning we keep
going producers in the broadcast in the
morning yes congratulations to all four
Diana have been a great one-two punch
and now Diane is taking the helm we are
ready to go anything